I hope that algorithm for incremental concept learning makes sense to you.
Here is another way of visualization that algorithm.
Imagine that an AI agent was given a positive example and the AI agent may
come up with a concept definition that covers that positive example.
Now let us suppose that the AI agent is given a negative example, and
this negative example is covered by the current concept definition. Well in
that case the current concept definition must be refined in such a way that
the negative example is excluded, while still including the positive example. So
you can visualize a new concept definition which includes the positive example,
but excludes the negative example. Now let us suppose that the AI agent is given
another positive example, in which case the AI agent must revise its definition
of the concept so that the new positive example is also included so that's
also covered. So we may revise this concept definition something like this. And
we can repeat this exercise many times. Imagine there is a negative example and
the current concept definition covers it.
Well, we can refine it in such a way that a new negative example is excluded and
so on. We can imagine going through several of these iterations of positive and
negative examples. Eventually we'll get a concept definition that includes,
that covers all the positive examples, and excludes all the negative examples.
So again, the problem is the same. Given a small set of positive and
negative examples, the number of dimensions in
which the algorithm can do generalization and specialization is very large.
How do, how do we constrain the learning in this complex learning space?
That's where those [UNKNOWN] and background knowledge come in.
The [UNKNOWN] guide the algorithm so that it revises the concept definition
in an efficient manner and the background knowledge helps in that process.